listening is childcare colleges and
universities when we move to step four
which is currently anticipated as the
19th of july
the prime minister announces that step
four will be able to remove swathes of
restrictions on daily life and that
after
16 months of sacrifice by those across
society
we will return ever closer to normality
we have faced down together a historic
public health emergency and that we all
owe
a great debt of gratitude to pupils
parents and teachers who have given
up so much as we have taken action
to save lives
i do however want to highlight to
everyone
that step four does not mean the end of
a pandemic and some restrictions will be
kept in place
while we move towards more of a
population being fully vaccinated
while the pandemic is not over we are
moving into a new
phase of managing covid from strict
rules
and towards ever more greater personal
responsibility
when i came to this place last week i
again
set out my priority to put the interests
of children first
we know from our own experience and
evidence that children
are better off in classrooms with their
friends and teachers
millions of children and young people
have been back in the classroom since
march the 8th learning with their
friends and teachers
this is hugely valuable for their
well-being as well as for their
education
i also made clear that i do not think
that it is acceptable that children
should face greater restrictions
over and above those of wider society
especially since they have given up so
much
to keep older generations safe during
this pandemic
so having balanced for risks i'm pleased
to tell members across the house
that key restrictions on education and
child care
will come to an end as we move to step
four
though keeping children in consistent
groups
was essential to control the spread of a
virus when our population
was less vaccinated we recognize that
the system of bubbles and isolation
is causing disruption to many children's
education
that is why we'll be ending bubbles and
transferring contract
contact tracing to the nhs test and
trace system
for early years settings schools and
colleges where there are outbreaks
schools and colleges may be contacted by
nhs test and trace and they will also
work with local health teams
as they currently do now
we're also setting out new rules that
mean that from the 16th of august
children will only need to isolate if
they have tested positive
for covid19 i'm also
pleased to be able to say there will be
no restrictions on in-person teaching
and learning in universities unless
students are advised to isolate
or impacted by local outbreaks from step
four
a more proportionate set of controls
will apply in early years
schools colleges and higher education
institutions
these will maintain a baseline of
protective
measures in education settings while
maximizing attendance
and minimizing disruption to children
and young people's education
in addition to ending bubbles it will
not be necessary to stagger start and
finish times
schools and colleges may of course
continue with these measures until the
end of the summer term
if they so wish
my write on board friend the health
secretary outlined earlier today
that we can ease restrictions on the
rules of self-isolation
for close contacts of someone who has
tested positive for co-fit 19.
in education settings all other existing
measures including guidance on
isolation of contacts will stay in place
until the end of this
term in line with isolation rules for
the
rest of the population as more adults
are vaccinated
settings will continue to have a role in
working with health protection teams in
the case for local outbreak
where necessary some measures may need
to be reintroduced
from august 16th those under the age of
18 years old
will no longer be required to
self-isolate
if they are contacted by nhs test and
trace
as a close contact of a positive covid
19 case this will balance the need
to keep children safe at the same time
as allowing them to get the education
that they deserve and need
instead children will be contacted by
test and trace
informed they have been in close contact
with a positive case
and advised to take a pcr test
eighteen-year-olds will be treated in
the same way as children
until four months after their 18th
birthday
to allow them to have the opportunity to
get fully vaccinated
having listened to teachers and
balancing the risks to
health and education to maximize
attendance and minimize disruption to
children and young people's education
some protective measures including
enhanced hygiene and ventilation
will remain in place for the autumn term
from step four face coverings will no
longer be advised for people
students staff and visitors either in
classrooms or in communal areas
and social distancing will no longer be
necessary
as i mentioned earlier testing programs
remain important
as we move cautiously out of
restrictions
with this in mind secondary schools and
colleges will be asked to provide
two on-site tests to their students at
the start of term
with regular home testing continuing
until the end of september
when this will be reviewed it is vital
that secondary school and college
students continue to test for the last
few weeks of this term
and throughout september education
settings were
still operating over summer will
continue to test twice a week
with asymptomatic test kits still
available
to families over the summer break as
well
i also want to encourage all teachers
educational staff
and eligible students to get their
vaccines
it is incredibly important for all staff
to get
the second dose of a vaccine as soon as
they are eligible
so they secure the strongest possible
protection
against covert 19.
in line with wiser changes to isolation
from august
16th if in close contact with someone
who has
tested positive fully vaccinated
teachers
will be able to remain in the classroom
from the autumn term
my department has just set out more
detail and published new guidance for
arrangements in education settings from
step four
covering both her summer period and the
following term
when children will return to school
i want to take this opportunity to
assure members that head teachers and
their constituencies can contact the
department of education
if they have any questions about the new
guidance that we have published
madam deputy speaker no government would
want to restrict people's freedom in the
way we have had to
since the spread of coven 19. we have
prioritized education since the start of
this pandemic
we made sure that schools and colleges
were the last to close
but for first to open we kept school and
college places open to vulnerable
children and those of key workers
throughout the pandemic
and procured millions of laptops and
tablets for children to learn
at home none of this could have been
achieved without the incredible work of
our
inspirational teachers and wider
educational staff
and i'd like to thank the parents and
students who have shown
patience and flexibility over the last
18 months
madam deputy speaker i know that many
colleagues will agree
that today as a nation we prize the role
of
schools colleges and universities
more than ever before with the ending of
these
restrictions children and young people
will be able to get back
on with their education and lives while
we continue to manage this pandemic
i commend the statement to the house